approché des jeunes mais parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup trop déconnecté de la
sphère politique il pense que ça va
ramener les jeunes à la politique dont
il se désintéresserait en lieu et place
de politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique pendant la rendant encore plus
qu on est justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour moissac
hommes politiques personnelles est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
nouveau d'utiliser des célébrités pour
faire de la propagande politique on s'en
fiche nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige
la france comme si son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions tout du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de ce soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent même si
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt plein
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 27 septembre les
tractations qui commence en coulisses au
lendemain des législatives en allemagne
le spd arrive en tête talonnée par la cd
ou cs ou parti de la chancelière un
cuisant revers néanmoins pour le camp
d'angela merkel les deux parties
revendiquent la possibilité de diriger
une coalition une période d'incertitude
qui pourrait bien priver ce poids lourds
européens de visibilité pendant de longs
mois sur la scène internationale nous
rejoindront dans quelques instants régis
le sommier sur place ça
quel avenir pour le mali dans sa lutte
anti-terrorisme la france est accusée
par bamako d'abandonner le pays en
retirant la force barkan à la tribune de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu le
gouvernement de transition a dénoncé
décision unilatérale de paris alors le
mali est il en passe de devenir
l'afghanistan français comment les
autorités maliennes compte elle garantir
la sécurité de ses habitants après le
départ des troupes françaises on ouvre
le dossier dans 30 minutes
et puis elle a eu une également la
politique française avec de nouvelles
sorties fracassantes d'eric zemmour le
polémiste qui ne s'est pourtant toujours
pas déclaré candidat officiel à la
présidentielle semble tout de même en
opération séduction auprès de son
électorat conservateur
il en profite pour torpiller les
républicains essaient ténor eric zemmour
qualifie
les élèves de parti de notables de
centristes avec des dirigeants qui ont
eux-mêmes trahi le général de gaulle
selon lui fin de citation
et puis enfin 21h notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français ce soir à l'heure
où les candidats à la présidentielle
déclarée aux noms commencent à faire
leurs propositions sur la politique de
la ville et des quartiers nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de ses habitants de
la cité des tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes
régulièrement la une de l'actualité pour
des affrontements entre jeunes et police
alors comment peut-on rétablir la
communication entre ces deux acteurs que
l'on oppose en permanence comment faire
revenir l'ordre républicain dans les
quartiers les politiques ont-ils la
bonne approche comprennent t'il vraiment
la réalité du terrain nous en
discuterons avec nos invités
l'allemagne dans le flou donc au
lendemain des législatives le centre
gauche signe son grand retour le parti
social démocrate remporte d'une courte
tête les élections fédérales selon les
résultats partiels le spd obtient pour
l'instant 25 7% des suffrages suivi de
peu par les conservateurs de la td ou cs
ou parti de la chancelière bref pas de
quoi pour l'instant élire un chancelier
ou une chancelière pour en parler on
retrouve à berlin notre grand reporter
régis le sommier bon soit régis le
candidat du parti social démocrate olaf
scholz c'est donc le proba le prochain
chancelier allemand c'est bien ça
le prochain chancelier allemand
évidemment il y aura toujours une
période de doute et puis il ya toujours
encore la possibilité que la cd ou de
dar mines l'achète forme elle même une
coalition avec les verts on peut
l'imaginer ou avec les
libéraux-démocrates c'est une
possibilité il y a si vous voulez
aujourd'hui néanmoins quand même quand
on venait dans berlin quand on discute
avec les berlinois le sentiment quand
même que ils ont
confiance dans le fait que ça sera bien
olaf scholz le prochain chancelier il ya
quand même une dynamique autour du
personnage et lui même d'ailleurs a dit
hier dès l'annoncé des résultats sortie
de sortie des urnes il s'est déclaré en
disant voilà les électeurs m'ont portée
pour devenir le nouveau chancelier donc
il a enfoncé le clou le matin ce matin
en disant qu'ils souhaitaient que la cd
ou soit dans l'opposition dont qui lui
barrent un peu la route à l'idée de
reformer vous savez ce qu'on a appelé la
grosse coalition' ici le lag rocco relie
le avec angela merkel à la tête et puis
le même hall h hall en vises vice
chancelier qui a exercé le pouvoir
jusqu'ici donc ce serait peut-être
c'était l'une des possibilité d'avoir
une coalition al'inverse avec le spd en
tête et puis le cd ou la cd ou pardon
est en réalité donc olafsen ce matin en
disant qu'ils souhaitaient que les
conservateurs haye dents dans
l'opposition ferme la porte à cette
option
l'option la plus probable qui semble se
dessiner aujourd'hui ce serait que le
spd face une alliance avec les verts et
aussi avec les libéraux-démocrates le
problème ça va être toute cette racaille
tractations l'entente depuis hier que ça
peut durer des mois pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les partis
évidemment les verts les libéraux
démocrates n'ont pas tout à fait la même
vision de la politique ni les mêmes
idées et qu'il va falloir que ils
discutent entre eux et ce sont ces deux
petits partis donc le parti emmené par
anna-lena beau berlocq et puis celui
amené emmenée par christian lindner qui
sont un petit peu aujourd'hui les
faiseurs de roi c'est eux qui pourront
avec laure 14% respectivement leur 11%
apporter la majorité nécessaire pour
l'élection l'hypothétique de dollars
schulz il y a donc une autre possibilité
aussi qui serait de faire une coalition
ce qu'on appelle rouges rouges verts se
seraient donc avec le spd avec les
communistes de die linke et avec les
verts et là on aurait vraiment un virage
à gauche c'est peu probable mais c'est
aussi une des possibilités donc tout ça
explique pourquoi pendant les semaines
qui viennent voir les ce mois qui
viennent souvenons nous lors des
dernières élections guélat merkel avait
dû batailler ferme pendant près de six
mois et on connaît la patience de la
chancelière pour obtenir à nouveau
pour assurer à nouveau sa réélection
donc c'est véritablement une bataille de
couloir qui est en train de se faire
avec une négociation avec des postes de
ministres qui vont être attribués aux
uns et aux autres le tout dans une
arithmétique électorale le propres à
l'allemagne et qui verra ensuite au
bundestag finalement la chambre basse
désigné à la majorité le nouveau
chancelier allemand donc régis
rapidement on l'aura compris il faudra
probablement encore sur cette élection
s'armer de patience si on vous suit bien
pour avoir le nom de la nouvelle ou du
nouveau chancelier
oui c'est souvent le cas en allemagne il
y a eu des moments où les élections
étaient plus claires plus marqué on dira
que au début de l'ère merkel en 2005
c'était plus facile de trouver une
coalition mais c'était déjà le cas
parce que il y avait les deux partis
principaux la cd ou et le spd formé à
peu près 70 % des voix aujourd'hui
l'électorat et beaucoup de plus morcelé
il est à l'image de la société allemande
qui est traversée d'un certain nombre
d'interrogations temps sur le climat sur
l'immigration sur la politique sociale
également à savoir donc en fait qui est
incarné par trois parties imaginez que
il ya trois parties qui suivent la cd ou
et le spd et qui sont à plus de 10% donc
ça veut dire que vraiment il ya un
morcellement de cet électorat est que la
cd ou et le spd faut à peine 50%
aujourd'hui et donc ils doivent trouver
des combinaisons pour pouvoir gouverner
pour pouvoir faire une coalition c'est
de tradition en allemagne mais c'est
probablement beaucoup plus difficile
cette fois ci et ça aura beaucoup de
conséquences évidemment parce que ça va
déterminer ma la politique intérieure de
l'allemagne son regard sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui restent en
gestation et qui n'ont pas été accompli
ou un certain nombre de points qui n'ont
pas été traités pendant l'ère merkel et
puis aussi à la politique internationale
et notamment le regard de l'allemagne
vis-à-vis de l'europe et le regard de
l'europe vis-à-vis de l'allemagne en
particulier la france qui on le sait va
bientôt prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne et qui aurait aimé
effectivement avoir un interlocuteur
nouveau pour pouvoir redémarrer
peut-être ce moteur franco allemand qui
a été si souvent le moteur de l'europe
je crois qu'ils aient enfin emmanuel
macron en tout cas ce serait très
désireux justement de d'insuffler un
nouveau cap à cette politique européenne
notamment regarder des prérogatives de
défense c'est des sujets qui ont déjà
été disputées entre emmanuel macron par
exemple et olaf scholz et il y à une
convergence là dessus mais pour le
moment ce ne sera pas olaf scholz qui va
inaugurer cette terre et on va avoir et
fine et finalement en gala merkel qu'on
donne donnée partante puisqu'elle a
décidé de ne pas se représenter mais
elles risquent de se gouverner encore
pendant des semaines voire des mois et
peut-être même jusqu'à noël à suivre
donc régis le sommier
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct de
berlin ce soir et même un on l'aura
compris si elle était menée à rester
encore quelques mois dans les habits de
la chancelière comme régis le sommier 20
nous l'expliqué ce scrutin tourne
néanmoins cette page de l'ère merkel la
chancelière sortante expédiera les
affaires courantes jusqu'à l'entrée en
fonction de son successeur
il sera élu par les députés du bundestag
au bundestag un coup d'oeil en images
sur le système politique allemand
[Musique]
et
là
[Musique]
non
l allemagne qui entrent donc dans une
longue période d'incertitude de quoi la
pris v1 temps de visibilité sur la scène
internationale un caillou également dans
le jardin de l'europe puisque berlin et
on le sait au centre des décisions de
l'union un renouvellement du paysage
politique qui pourrait donc bien
rebattre les cartes avec eux au centre
évidemment le couple franco allemand
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage ce
soit
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler edouard husson
historien spécialiste des relations
france-allemagne dont soir edouard
husson merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en direct un petit peu plus loin
jean bizet ancien sénateur heller
président de la commission des affaires
européennes bonsoir jean bizet merci
d'être avec nous en direct un mot tout
d'abord edouard husson sur les résultats
de ces législatives un régis le sommier
nous en a parlé mais enfin on l'aura
compris difficile évidemment de
constituer une majorité
vu les minettes mandé des suffrages en
cours de ce scrutin et ça peut
clairement durer cette affaire ça peut
durer c'est très difficile de prévoir
malgré tout je pense que les le système
politique tel qu'il est va essayer
d'éviter ce qui est arrivé en gala
merkel en 2017 où elle a mis six mois à
à constituer un gouvernement donc là je
crois qu'ils vont essayer d'aller plus
vite et 2 et de créer la surprise
effectivement armin laschet tu le
candidat de la cd ou s'accrochent mais
il ya quand même c'est quand même son
parti qu'elle plus perdu et donc la
dynamique est du côté du spd tout dépend
comme s'était dit tout à l'heure dans le
reportage tout dépend de la manière dont
le fdp les verts peuvent s'entendre pour
poser leurs conditions séparément et
ensemble au spd
c'est pas gagné mais
il va y avoir deux politiques
expérimentés christian lindner d'un côté
roberto avec de l'autre qui va le
prendre la main je crois pour les verts
et à ce moment là on pourrait avoir moi
je fais plutôt le pari d'un dénouement
plus rapide que prévu enfin en tout cas
je vous propose d'écouter avant me fait
réagir jean bizet armin laschet tu qui
comme vous l'avez dit on s'accroche il a
refusé de jeter l'épongé malgré le score
historiquement bas de son parti côte et
nous pouvons déjà dire que nous ne
pouvons pas être satisfaits des
résultats
je la fais saison quand google a merkel
s'est présenté comme chancelière ce
furent 16 bonne année pour l'allemagne
et je tiens donc avant tout à remercier
la chancellière angela merkel pour son
travail
un jean bizet clairement amène hachette
qui a assumé sa part déchets que c'est
véritablement la fin de l'ère merkel
saison 2 de stabilité politique en
allemagne
je dirais très clairement que ça y
ressemble
d'autant plus que si on regarde un peu
plus finement les résultats on
s'aperçoit si vous voulez qu'il y à un
vote générationnel entre les anciens
partis cd ou ses sous et spd et puis les
libéraux et les verts et la jeunesse a
majoritairement choisi ces deux derniers
petits partis en quelque sorte que non
seulement vont être le faiseur de roi
mais son sur un certain nombre de
domaines notamment dans matière je
dirais climatique transition énergétique
ce qui ce qui vous comptez demain donc
moi je pense que madame merkel a eu une
période assez extraordinaire elle a été
entre guillemets l'homme fort de
l'europe c'est aujourd'hui l'heure des
changements mais je pense qu'elle aura
encore un rôle pendant les semaines qui
viennent tout simplement parce que la
présence française devant démarrer le
1er janvier 2022
il y à fort à parier qu'elle jouera de
tout son poids pour faire en sorte que
l'allemagne soit je dirais en position
je dirais opérationnelles
avant la présence française
effectivement parce que vous l'avez dit
edouard ils sont ce précédent scrutin de
2010 est il y avait laissé un petit peu
l'allemagne en paralysie face scène
internationale six mois a constitué un
gouvernement ce que clairement il ya ce
risque à nouveau d'autant que comme jean
wiesel a dit l'allemagne prend la
présidence du g 7 ans en 2022 il ya
cette crainte en tout cas en allemagne
alors je crois que si vous voulez
beaucoup dépend aussi pour pour olaf
scholz de la dynamique qui là qu'il a
créé et qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
absolument irrésistible mais qui malgré
tout existe est ce que les allemands ont
dit dans les sondages avant l'élection
ce qu'ils ont confirmé par le vote
d'hier c'est que il préférait la
personnalité de la volt et ils le
voyaient comme plus apte à gouverner
parce qu'il a une apparemment une plus
forte personnalité carmine l'achète et
donc je pense que que salt n'a pas
intérêt à ce que ça s'éternise il a
plutôt intérêt à donner l'impression que
avec lui les choses redémarrent pas ce
qu'il faut nuancer un point concernant
le dernier mandat de madame merkel elle
est redevenue elle a été malgré lui il
ya quatre ans et elle est redevenue
populaire il ya deux ans quand on a su
qu'elle ne se représenterait plus est
donc là les pour beaucoup d'allemands il
s'agit de se remettre au travail alors
la france en tant que ex élu jean bizet
la france doit de traître être parent
dans inquiète au moment justement où
vieux continent redoutent une forme de
marginalisation géopolitique face à
certaines rivalités des états unis on
l'a vu récemment de la chine de la
russie
écoutez fille nous avons salué entre
guillemets la stabilité le calme
d'angela merkel pendant ses années de
pouvoir
nous ne pouvons que regretter
elle prend sarkozy l'a exprimé avec
beaucoup plus de vigueur pendant des
années
de réactivité de l'allemagne et
aujourd'hui ce manque de réactivité est
d'autant plus serait d'autant plus
crucial que nous avons affaire à une
situation extrêmement délicate avec le
nouveau positionnement de la chine
lections monsieur joe biden et puis le
départ de nos amis britanniques
donc l'europe doit faire preuve de
beaucoup plus de réactivité
si elle veut se positionner dans un
environnement je dirais qu'il ne soit
plus uniquement un dialogue entre la
chine et les états unis là l'europe a
besoin d'un véritable rupture elle
prétendait république emmanuel macron
qui va commencer également parallèlement
sa campagne et or à l'habileté on peut
lui faire confiance surtout que à ses
côtés son conseiller europe clément
bonnet particulièrement habile et
compétente pour jouer précisément cette
carte est que nous sommes vis-à-vis de
l'allemagne à l'heure des changements et
un changement de tempo il ya un
changement d'acteur et on voit très bien
que si un certain nombre de points
marquant ses parts entre guillemets les
libéraux les verts et le spd
quand on est un peu plus en détail où on
voit qu'il ya des évolutions possibles
en france ce serait impossible mais avec
aussi c'est possible on voit très bien
que
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et la
politique de défense
les verts ont fait quelques progrès
de plus il est à parier que monsieur
chose
qui aura à écouter et à faire des
propositions à l'adresse des libéraux
verra très bien la soif je dirais de
pouvoir cette fois ci de christian
lindner et donc son souhait de
participer à une coalition
il a d'ailleurs fait savoir qu'il
voulait être le futur ministre des
finances qui n'est pas forcément une
très bonne nouvelle pour la france mais
après tout dans une coalition dans un
tel traité de gouvernement tout va se
négocier et dans le sens paris à régis
un dit espérer avoir vite un chancelier
allemand fort à ses côtés pour faire
avancer l'europe notamment durant sa
présidence tournante de l'ue à partir de
janvier comme nous l'expliqué jean bizet
l'europe est à un moment charnière de
son histoire
les pro européens doivent-ils sans
inquiéter justement de tous ces
changements aussi bien du côté de
l'allemagne peut-être de la france dans
quelques mois on ne sait pas alors je
crois si vous voulez que
il est il est difficile d'imaginer que
le président français quel que soit son
influence en europe et est la capacité à
faire accélérer le jeu politique
allemand il ya beaucoup de choses qui
nous échappent et moi je crois par
conséquent qui a peut-être une carte à
jouer
une carte à jouer qui est celle de se
dire on va être effectivement face au
premier gouvernement allemand tripartite
dont le rythme de décision va forcément
être plus long que ce qu'il était jusque
là et donc c'est à la france de savoir
ce qu'elle veut alors effectivement de
donner l'impulsion il ya peut-être une
une fenêtre de tir là pour qui les liait
finalement une réaffirmation
d'une forme de de présence plus forte
dans le dans le partenariat franco
allemand du côté de la france avec
simplement un bémol à m c'est que à la
fin de son quinquennat emmanuel macron
laisse une france très endetté et que ça
ça ne passe pas en allemagne et ça
disons que ça a affaibli beaucoup de ces
prises de position et ses demandes et
donc je crois que l' équilibre subtil
c'est effectivement préparer la
présidence de l'union européenne mais
c'est aussi en même temps qu'ils se
projettent vraisemblablement vers une
campagne de pour pour solliciter sa
réélection de montrer aux allemands que
il n'y a pas une espèce de deux courbes
toujours ascendante des déficits
français et qu' il y a des efforts qui
seront faits parce que sinon il y aura
ce rythme très lent de la politique
allemande et une france peu crédible et
à ce moment là on n'avancera pas on
restera dans l'entre-deux où on est
actuellement et jean bizet justement on
connaît les allemands très attachés à
cette rigueur
budgétaire au sein de l'europe quel que
soit aujourd'hui la coalition ce sera
d'une certaine manière la même chose
pour la france où il faudra se plier
justement à certaines exigences en
fonction
c'est une évidence que c'est c'est le
grand temps de entendent tendon
d'achille de la france et son taux
d'endettement et ça
faculté à
se réformer avec beaucoup de réticence
mais au delà de
l'hématite franco allemand les chiffres
ne peuvent pas mentir et on voit très
bien que ce soit du côté de l'as fait
donc du côté de la banque centrale
européenne est bien la politique si je
puis dire des taux va évoluer et on voit
très bien que quelques dixièmes de taux
supplémentaires
sur les emprunts faut faire en sorte que
la dette va de plus en plus devenir
littéralement insoutenable pour la
france donc
au delà de la vue des allemands c'est un
impératif national
auquel on ne pourra pas échapper
alors c'est vrai aussi qu'on se pose
parfois nous observateurs
la question de cette relation entretenue
par le couple franco-allemand
illustration en pleine crise des
sous-marins qu'on a vécu ici même la
semaine dernière berlin qui signent un
partenariat
spatiale un militaire avec l'australie
comme on le voit sur ces images c'était
la une du figaro cette même semaine
l'accord sur ariane 6 nous et mi juillet
entre la france et l'allemagne qui entre
en vigueur avec pour conséquence directe
le transfert outre-rhin de la production
du moteur de la fusée
spatiale regardez cette une d'ailleurs
de lusine nouvelles dont 860 salariés à
vernon dans l'eure qui vont en faire les
frais edouard husson ça vous inspire
quoi ça ce sont voilà les jeux de 2
entre amis ou faut-il s'en sont
inquiétés de ce mouvement si vous voulez
je crois qu'il n'y a rien de nouveau
au sens où l'allemagne a toujours
considéré que c'est pas parce qu'on est
amis qu'il n'y a pas une une émulation
une compétition ça s'appelle l'ordo
libéralisme et donc chacun joue sa carte
en respectant les règles partagées
cependant si vous voulez je crois que
cet enchaînement d'événements vous avez
très bien
synthétisé devrait être l'occasion d'une
prise de conscience assez rapide à paris
que effectivement ça ne ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça nous avons aussi des
intérêts à défendre et ses intérêts il
faut les défendre effectivement dans le
cadre européen mais de manière beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus clair vis-à-vis de
nos amis allemands qui eux si vous
voulez quand le chancelier kohl
autrefois disait l'allemagne et l'europe
sont les deux faces d'une même monnaie
ou l'europe et l'allemagne 10 et il a
l'intention de ses de ses compatriotes
il faut pas il faut pas oublier que ça
voulait dire que en europe l'allemagne
entendait être pleinement elle même est
un je pense d'ailleurs que c'était la
conception aussi qu'avait le général de
gaulle delà de la communauté économique
européenne et il serait temps de ce
point de vue là que ça soit macron de où
monsieur x il serait temps de revenir à
cette scène conception des choses parce
que sinon effectivement le le couple
franco-allemand s'étiolera justement
coup d'oeil sur les principaux dans la
lignée de ce qu'on vient de dire sur les
principaux partenaires commerciaux de
l'allemagne ce sont les chiffres
regarder de l'office fédéral de la
statistique
allemand pour 2017 on constate un que la
chine et les etats-unis sont les
premiers partenaires commerciaux de
berlin je me pose la même question jean
bizet ce que les allemands jouent
vraiment le la carte de l'europe et
faut-il al'inverse être peut-être
davantage nous aussi nationaliste
je pense qu'il faut davantage d'europe
en la matière si je reviens de seconde
sur la sphère des sous marins qui est
hôte qui ne se résume pas simplement à
la vente je dirais de bâtiments mais les
commandes à geler les australiens ont
aussi acheté la paix avec la rage la
participation des états unis d des
anglais dans cette affaire mais je pense
que ce dossier aurait peut-être eu une
autre allure si précisément l'europe
avait su s'entendre en la matière si
navale groupe avait suisses entendent
avec thyssen krupp sur le sujet tant que
nous n'aurons pas une intégration
je dirais supplémentaire que ce soit en
matière de fédéralisme budgétaire on a
tout petit début de fédéralisme
budgétaire suite à la halle épidémique
au vide tant que nous ne ferons pas
davantage je dirais de politique
économique plus intégrée et bien on aura
des des dossiers comme ceux ci on aura
des poussée de nationalisme
ce qui est assez malsain et dressant le
mot de la fin pour vous partager
une vision un peu différente
je pense que nous sommes nous sommes à
un tournant pour la politique française
qui doit qui doit en fait revenir
à une conception - fédéraliste et plus
et plus plus gaullienne on dira où
l'europe se fait par les états membres
et je crois que là le grand problème le
grand problème que rencontre la france
actuellement vis-à-vis de son partenaire
allemand c'est que nous ne sommes plus
assez fort le partenariat est devenu
asymétrique et donc je crois que il ya
là avec un gouvernement allemand faible
ce qui n'empêchera pas l'industrie
allemands de continuer à tourner les les
ingénieurs allemands de continuer à
travailler les scientifiques allemands
de continuer à innover et bien nous
avons malgré tout une occasion
historique c'est puisque nous aurons une
allemagne plus morcelé politiquement
peut-être que nous nous pouvons faire
preuve de plus de cohésion et mieux
savoir ce que nous voulons et le dire à
nos amis allemands merci en tout cas
tous les deux edouard husson jean bizet
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage
ce soir merci
et on le disait un pari qui dit espérer
avoir vite un chancelier allemand fort à
ses côtés pour faire avancer l'europe
durant sa présidence tournante à partir
de janvier réaction également du côté de
la russie le kremlin qui dègla déclare
vouloir la continuité dans les relations
avec berlin la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine clairon à moscou aussi on a
suivi de près ses élections législatives
en allemagne on va continuer de suivre
les tractations à venir dans l'optique
de la formation d'une nouvelle majorité
ce afin de connaître finalement
l'identité de celui ou celle qui va
succéder à angela merkel en tout cas du
côté du kremlin une seule chose importe
conserver des relations constructives
avec berlin
les élections dans le plus grand pays
d'europe c'est un processus un événement
qui bien sûr attire l'attention du monde
entier ou presque
nous observons avec le grande attention
ce qui se passe quels sont les résultats
bien entendu nous comptons sur la
continuité de nos relations bilatérales
sympa exemple de désaccord nous sommes
unis par la compréhension aucun problème
ne peut et ne doit être résolue que par
la voie du dialogue en outre l'allemagne
est bien entendu autre très grand
partenaire commercial économique et
d'investissement
nous avons intérêt à ce que notre
relation se prolonge et se développe ce
que nous comprenons le processus de
formation d'une coalition sera long et
complexe par conséquent il nous allons
regarder comment ce processus va se
dérouler berlin est en effet un
partenaire incontournable de moscou en
europe en témoigne la construction du
gazoduc north stream ii entre
l'allemagne et la russie via la mer
baltique qui s'est achevée il ya tout
juste quelques semaines sur ce dossier
comme sur d'autres les autorités russes
espèrent donc une continuité de la part
du nouveau gouvernement allemand qui
reste donc encore à composer
la question à présent du retrait du mali
des forces françaises de l'opération
barkan qui s'est invité ce week-end dans
les débats de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu à la tribune premier ministre
malien du gouvernement de transition a
directement attaqué un parent il
accusant d'abandonner son pays on
retrouve notre correspondante au
m'abonner à washington bonsoir thomas
bamako qui semble avoir du mal à digérer
le départ de l'opération barkan et la
façon de faire
absolument le premier ministre malien a
profité de la tribune de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies à new york
pour délivrer un message fort à
destination de paris choquel maïga est
revenu donc sur la décision d' emmanuel
macron de réduire la présence militaire
dans le cadre de l'opération barkan
rappelez-vous le président français
avait annoncé au mois de juillet dernier
la fermeture de certaines bases et la
réduction des effectifs militaires
déployés qui pourrait passer de plus de
5000 aujourd'hui à 3000 à l'horizon
2023 et bien le premier ministre malien
dénonce de son côté un manque de
concertation et de consultation écoutez
le
le mali regrettes que le principe de
consultation et de concertation qui doit
être la règle entre partenaires
privilégiés n'est pas été observé en
amont de la décision du gouvernement
français la nouvelle situation née de la
fin de barkan la salle le mali devant le
fait accompli et l'exposent à une espèce
d'abandon en plein vol nous conduit à
explorer les voies et moyens pour mieux
assurer la sécurité de manière autonome
avec d'autres partenaires
le premier ministre malien qui rejette
aussi l'idée d'un développement d'un
sentiment anti français au mali un état
de fait qui est pourtant relativement
étayée par un certain nombre de
témoignages qui nous arrive du mali
depuis ces derniers mois et thomas ce
discours qui intervient en tout cas au
moment où la diplomatie française
s'inquiète du fait que bamako se tourner
vers d'autres partenaires
oui parce que la semaine dernière déjà à
new york lors d'un entretien entre jean
yves le drian et sergueï lavrov le
dossier malien avait déjà été abordée
paris avait fixé une ligne rouge site
avant l'avertissant le chef de la
diplomatie russe des conséquences graves
de l'implication du groupe wagner au
mali une injonction à laquelle a répondu
sergueï lavrov
ah c'était donc ce samedi lors de sa
conférence de presse au siège des
nations unies à new york
les autorités de transition
continue d'ailleurs cette lutte contre
le terrorisme et dans cette optique ils
se sont adressés à des compagnies
armée privée
parce que la france a si j'ai bien
compris décidé de réduire
significativement sa présence militaire
donc les autorités maliennes ont estimé
que leurs forces étaient insuffisantes
sans aide extérieure et comme l'aide de
ceux qui aiment qui s'était engagé à
déraciner le
terrorisme donc bas du cool ce il
s'adresse à des compagnies
militaires privées russes nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça et cela le concerne
que le gouvernement légitime ce qui est
considéré comme le les forces de
transition légitime et ceux qui
proposent ce genre de service
a aussi expliqué qu'il avait discuté de
ce dossier avec le chef de la diplomatie
de l'union européenne josep borrell et
ce dernier lui aurait fait comprendre
que l'afrique était en quelque sorte un
pré carré européen et que la russie n'y
avait donc n'avait donc rien à y faire
alors moscou de son côté appelle à une
concertation et un travail conjoint dans
le respect des règles internationales
mais comme l'a répété cette semaine la
semaine dernière l'union européenne le
recours par bamako à des partenaires
privés comme la société wagner mènerait
à une reconsidération du déploiement
européen au mali merci thomas bonnin en
direct de washington et pour approfondir
le sujet nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison les militaires on l'a dit
un français qui doivent quitter d'ici la
fin de l'année les bases sains situés
dans le nord du mali beaucoup de choses
évidemment on reste en suspens comme l'a
précisé premier ministre malien alors
une question le mali est il en passe de
devenir l'afghanistan français a
beaucoup de points communs entre
l'afghanistan et le mali d'abord parce
que le fait générateur de l'intervention
était l'appel d'un gouvernement légitime
du mali
à la suite de la conquête par des
djihadistes de ville dans le nord du
mali de la dévastation de tombouctou y
compris des bibliothèques musulmane de
tombouctou et le danger de bamako d'être
pris par ces milices venus du nord donc
l'origine est tout à fait différente ça
n'a rigoureusement rien à voir ensuite
le théâtre d'opération est plus large
que le mali c'est le sahel est en
réalité les pays voisins sont également
impliqués le niger le burkina faso le
tchad la mauritanie c'est ce qu'on
appelle le g5 et il ya eu d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises et sommet des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement du g 5 l'un
d'entre eux a eu lieu en juillet dernier
en vidéoconférence à cause du que vides
et à ceux à ce g5 le président français
a expliqué que en effet ils allaient
redéployer le dispositif barkan 5000
plus de 5000 soldats français
aujourd'hui 52 morts le 52e c'était la
semaine dernière donc on peut pas dire
que la france a été inactif dans cette
affaire d'autre part il y à une
résolution de l'onu il ya une force de
l'onu sur place la minus mas qui joue
son rôle et il ya également quelques
troupes de d'états membres européens qui
constitue à l'embryon d'une force
européenne que la france appelle de ses
voeux depuis plusieurs années mais qui
tarde un petit peu en effet à se mettre
en place alors c'est différent et en
effet le mali est un pays francophone
qui fait partie de la francophonie il ya
80 milles malien en france donc tout ça
fait que ça n'a pas beaucoup de rapport
avec le malheureux précédent afghans
alors il n'empêche en devant la
communauté internationale le premier
ministre malien lui c'est clairement
plaint de la façon dont s'est effectué
le retrait des forces françaises barkan
au mali bamako a raison de pointer du
doigt cette stratégie française le
premier ministre malien a ses raisons
des raisons de politique intérieure et
des raisons de politique extérieure les
raisons de politique intérieure c'est
qu'il a été nommé premier ministre le 11
juin dernier par la junte militaire
puisque il ya eu quand même eu un coup
d'état au mali aubrey doute 2020 et la
cedeao le la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'est de l'ouest à est venu
à plusieurs reprises d'envoyer des
missions parce que ça lui déplaisait qui
est un régime militaire à bamako et le
colonel qui a pris le pouvoir et la
junte avait dû promettre à la cedeao
d'avoir un premier ministre civil il y
en a eu un qui n'a pas fait la faire
parce qu'il n'allait pas prendre ses
instructions au bonne endroit c'est à
dire auprès de la junte est donc un
nouveau premier ministre a été nommé au
mois de juin celui ci prend sans doute
cesser d'instruction là où il faut et en
effet
et puis là il a hélas il est dans une
situation délicate par rapport à la
junte et il y a aussi le deuxième volet
qui est le volet externe en effet la
situation de sécurité n'est pas bonne au
mali en effet les dispositifs dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure bach cale le
dispositif du g5 sahel le dispositif de
la minus ma le dispositif européen ne
sont pas performants et par conséquent
il a en effet dit à des journalistes en
marge de cette intervention à l'onu que
le gouvernement de bamako recherchait un
peu partout des possibilités de résoudre
ce problème de sécurité mais parce qu il
précise que la situation en tout cas
selon lui toujours sécuritaire ne s'est
pas améliorée malgré les forces
étrangères que les habitants la
population continuer à souffrir sur sur
le terrain de ces menaces terroristes
alors justement quelle alternative
aujourd'hui pour pour le mali il en a
cité une à la tribune des nations unies
la presse n'a pas beaucoup souligné cet
aspect après avoir critiqué en effet
l'inefficacité barkan après huit ans les
jihadistes ont changé de tactique du
plusieurs fois durant ces huit ans il a
dit il faudrait que le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies modifie le
mandat de la minus ma pour le rendre
plus opérationnel et est plus agressif
puisque la minus m'a finalement observe
plus que combat les djihadistes donc
c'est une voix est ce que le conseil de
sécurité qui avaient voté une résolution
il ya huit ans sur ce sujet est prêt en
voter une autre ça dépend des cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité évidemment une des autres voix
est celle qui a été mentionné tout à
l'heure dans votre sujet
il ya bien sûr la solution ou si c'est
une solution de milices privées ou de
deux groupes militaires russes puisque
monsieur lavrov a dit qu'il fait et
russes mais privés qui n'avaient pas de
rapport avec le gouvernement russe il ya
aussi probablement les américains qui
joue un rôle important parce que
actuellement toutes les opérations repos
sur un ravitaillement en vol des avions
par les états unis
50% des informations donc de 2,2 tout ce
qui relève de l' aider des services
d'information des services secrets vient
des états unis et puis aussi des
éléments de transport qui viennent des
états unis donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont concernés et s'il ya des eaux
d'autres nouveaux intervenants bien
entendu ils devront se concerter avec
ceux qui sont déjà sur place ne
serait-ce que pour éviter d'entrer en
collision les uns avec les autres c'est
ce qu'on appelle la dé confection merci
un mot voilà quand je viens d'apprendre
merci claude blanchet raison pour cet
éclairage
elles disent craindre un retour à la
dictature ben ali des centaines de
personnes ont manifesté hier à tunis
contre kelly sayed rassemblement plus
important que celui de la semaine
précédente
les protestataires dénoncent les mesures
exceptionnelles décidées par le
président tunisien est la correspondance
à tunis de bsn chebbi
constitution liberté et dignité
nationale à des nombreux slogans qu'on
pouvait lire sur les pancartes des
manifestants réunis dimanche devant le
théâtre municipal de tunis plus d'un
millier de personnes s'étaient donné
rendez-vous à l'appel de certains partis
d'opposition comme le parti islamiste
ennahda ou encore le parti el karama
pour dénoncer les mesures
exceptionnelles décrété par le président
saïd renforçant ainsi et ses pouvoirs un
important dispositif de sécurité avait
été déployé sur l'avenue bourguiba au
coeur de la capitale pour prévenir tout
risque de débordements entre les pro et
anti el sayed pour les opposants au chef
de l'état autant de pouvoirs entre les
mains d'un seul homme constitue un
risque pour les acquis démocratiques de
la révolution de 2011 certains n'ont pas
hésité à comparer l'actuel président à
l'ancien autocrate zine abedine ben ali
disant craindre un retour à l'état
policier écouter
aujourd'hui en tant que représentant du
peuple nous sommes toujours dans notre
capacité parlementaire selon tous les
décret constitutionnel du président de
la république qui a renversé la
constitution de la deuxième république
aujourd'hui nous sortons dans la rue et
nous nous opposons au coup d'état le
coup d'état qu'est devenu décisif en
tunisie le coût qui est menée pour
violer la constitution tunisienne et
tous ces chapitres
aujourd'hui nous sommes ici pour
défendre la liberté les institutionnels
pour lesquelles nos martyrs sont morts
et pour lesquels nous avons vécu
soixante ans de sacrifices pour avoir un
pays démocratique
aujourd'hui nous exigeons le retour du
système républicain qui a été abolie et
le retour de la constitution à laquelle
on fait référence pour passer à un
régime populiste anti constitutionnel
nous voulons continuer avec la
constitution de 2014
elles viennent de militants de
l'opposition d'acteurs de la société
civile ou de juristes de plus en plus de
voix s'élèvent contre les décisions du
président sayed notamment au sujet d'un
texte publié au journal officiel qui se
substitue à plusieurs articles de la
constitution et contient de nouvelles
mesures d'exception le 25 juillet
dernier kaïs saïd avait surpris tout le
monde en limogeant le premier ministre
et en gelant les activités du parlement
deux mois plus tard alors que le palais
de carthage devrait annoncer
prochainement la nomination d'un nouveau
chef du gouvernement les tunisiens
demeure dans l'expectative car la
perspective d'une sortie de crise
politique reste incertaine
l'actualité politique en france avec
emmanuel macron déplacement aujourd'hui
au salon international de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie et de
l'alimentation à lyon scène cocasse lors
de cette visite le chef de l'état qui a
été visée par un g2 dans les allées du
salon hauteur du geste qui aurait crié
vive la révolution été interpellé sur le
plan des mesures en faveur des
restaurateurs le président a annoncé la
défiscalisation des pourboires versés
par carte bancaire aux employés des
cafés et restaurants
on va passer les textes là dans les
prochaines semaines pour qu'à partir des
plus vite possible les tout prochains
mois on puisse avoir des pourboires qui
seront défiscalisées et s'en charge et
qui seront permis par la carte bleue et
donc l'idée c'est quoi ses complices au
restaurant payer le pourboire avec la
carte bleue l'arrondi ou plus parce
qu'on l'a vu en sortie de crise nos
compatriotes utilisent de moins en moins
de liquide deuxièmement que c'est pour
voir soi sans charge pour les employeurs
que vous êtes et que c'est pour voir soi
sans impôt pour les salariés qui les
reçoivent ce qui va permettre d'ajouter
au pouvoir d'achat de ces derniers
et lors de ce même déplacement emmanuel
macron été interrogé sur la possible
candidature d'eric zemmour qui fait
beaucoup parler en ce moment évidemment
le président a botté en touche et n'a
pas souhaité répondre aux questions des
journalistes pendant ce temps le
principal intéressé lui continue
d'entretenir le flou tout en étant
largement devant la scène médiatique et
politique critiquant ses potentiels
adversaires on retrouve et celle farges
devant le siège du parti des
républicains bonsoir estelle alors
pourquoi les républicains parce que ce
sont la nouvelle cible des critiques
d'eric zemmour
exactement stéphanie un parti de
notables sont tristes voilà comment eric
zemmour a qualifié ce week-end le parti
à l'est républicain
le polémiste inquiets accusent les
républicains d'avoir trahi la droite
gaulliste dont lui-même se réclame ils
prétendent que je ne partage pas leur
valeur mais eux mêmes en quoi
partage-t-il les valeurs du rpr et de la
droite d'avant ils ont eux-mêmes traille
et le général de gaulle et même georges
pompidou ce sont elles les mots d'eric
azemmour le polémiste qui s'est aussi
exprimé sur la candidature de marine le
pen à la présidentielle la candidate du
rassemblement national qui selon eric
zemmour a des réflexes de femmes de
gauche pour le polémiste si le
rassemblement national a autant
progressé c'est justement parce que le
rpr a été nié et a été trahi hessel est
ce que les républicains ont réagi
me stéphanie il ya différents à son de
cloche on va commencer par celui du
président des républicains alors qu'il
était interrogé sur les déclarations à
d'eric zemmour par nos confrères de bfm
tv christian jacob a estimé à quel
manqué d'un peu de modestie et
d'humilité
le président a délais requis dlr qui
considère qu eric zemmour est utile au
débat public mais que sa ligne n'est pas
celle des républicains à la question de
savoir si eric zemmour était d'extême
d'extrême droite christian jacob a tout
simplement retoqué il est aisé moore des
propos qui ne met pas tout le monde
d'accord au sein du parti jean françois
copé par exemple a dit penser le
contraire pour le maire de meaux eric
zemmour déroule un discours d'extrême
droite dont je cite les excès finissent
par affadir marine le pen il a appelé à
la droite à tenir bon et à exclure toute
alliance avec lui une ligne rouge rouge
intangible nous n'acceptons pas les
alliances avec l'extrême droite a
renchéri valérie pécresse qui espère
représenter les républicains à la
présidentielle merci et celles chargées
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alexis alors
décidément eric zemmour qui aime jouer
les trouble fête dans dans cette
campagne alors qu'on doit le rappeler il
n'est pas encore candidat c'est dans son
intérêt de laisser planer le doute parce
qu'il peut continuer d'être ce sniper et
de dire que tout le monde est nul sauf
lui alors lui n'a aucun programme mais
ce n'est pas grave il peut continuer de
dire que les républicains sont trop mous
que marine le pen est trop à gauche et
que lui c'est le rpr qui les gaullistes
alors même qu'il n'y l'héritage du
général de gaulle lorsqu'il et
révisionniste 1 pour dire que pétain a
sauvé des juifs de france la réalité est
triste non le maréchal pétain a fait en
sorte que des juifs français soit
déporté il faut le redire c'est du
révisionnisme et on le laisse dire en
plateau c'est bien tout le problème
d'eric zemmour ça qu'il peut être dans
l'outrance perpétuelle permanente il
court il court le zemmour et n'arrête
jamais de raconter à peu près n'importe
quoi sans programme puisqu'il n'est pas
candidat officiellement et de continuer
de dire que les autres ne sont pas à la
hauteur alors un moment il va falloir
qu'il se déclare et qu'il aussi annonce
une équipe et un vrai programme au delà
de sa marotte de ce qui fait son succès
finalement d'avoir dénoncé une certaine
islamisation de la république de la
france le risque étant là mais qu'est ce
qu'il se passe après cela quand on
demande à eric zemmour qu'est ce que
vous faites des gens qui ne veulent pas
s'assimiler qu'est ce que vous faites
des gens qui ont le prénom mohamed alors
là il ya plus personne n'y a pas de plan
en réalité parce qu'ils les polémistes
et il a bien du mal à être un candidat
donc c'est facile pour lui il a intérêt
à rester comme ça le plus longtemps
possible pour vendre son livre est une
question évidemment qui revient souvent
désormais comment classer eric zemmour
on viens de l'entendre jean françois
copé qui nous dit qu'il est d antigua
qu'il tient un discours d d'extrême
droite alors c'est un opni alors hop
nice et objet politique non identifié
c'est ça alors look ni je dirais que
c'est plutôt emmanuel macron qui n'est
ni de droite ni de gauche qui n'est pas
là qui n'est nulle part qui n'a aucune
colonne vertébrale idéologique si ce
n'est à un néolibéralisme mou la
social-démocratie en quelque sorte celle
merkel français emmanuel macron donc
c'est plutôt lui qui est non identifiés
et le succès zemmour vient de là c'est à
dire que lui il creuse un sillon le même
depuis des dizaines d'années celui de
lutter contre l'islamisation celui aussi
de revenir assure cette idée de faire un
rpr de se dire gaulliste alors qu'il
défend des idées de jean marie le pen
revenir sur les lois mémorielles revenir
aussi sur les cours de justice
internationale tout ce qu'il dit eric
zemmour il est très facilement classable
à l'extrême droite en réalité avec
évidemment la différence que ce n'est
pas l'extrême droite de jean marie le
pen à l'époque puisque jean marie le pen
lui était avait une partie antisémites
avaient toute cette frange la historique
la zemmour c'est assez différent mais ça
reste quand même assez classique dans ce
discours pareil sur le déclin de la
france c'est quelque chose qu'on a
toujours entendu dans les cercles
d'extrême droite ça ne change pas non
plus donc il n'ya pas de question à se
poser aussi nu si on a une la réponse
est facile oui eric zemmour pour moi et
d'extrême droite et alexis ponnet
évidemment les républicains on en parle
également parce qu'ils ont passé une
étape quand même important pour eux ce
week-end ils ont choisi de désigner
finalement leur montvidas sous la forme
d'un congrès pas d'une primaire c'est
une trahison pour les électeurs de
droite qu'est ce que ce choix signifie
ce choix est difficilement
compréhensible en réalité parce que on a
là un party les républicains qui était
un grand parti qui vient justement de
cette frange gaulliste puis qui a fait
l'ump puis les républicains et qui se
recroqueville sur lui-même on a
l'impression que les républicains en
tant que parti aujourd'hui a peur de
redevenir un parti populaire donc c'est
un parti effectivement et là on peut
donner raison à eric zemmour de notables
de gens qui décident entre eux
finalement derrière des portes closes de
qui sera le candidat et la chose en plus
la plus extraordinaire c'est que vous
allez avoir au sein de ce congrès des
gens comme xavier bertrand et valérie
pécresse qui ne sont plus encarté qui
vont venir quand même chercher
l'adoubement de ce parti donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose
d'incompréhensible pour un militant et
c'est aussi la question qui se pose
finalement là encore on peut voir la
patte des manuels macron qui après avoir
déconstruit la gauche puisque c'est à la
mode de déconstruire en ce moment est en
train de déconstruire la droite ou du
moins la droite le fait tout seul avec
ceux qui ne veulent pas le dire mais qui
sont déjà en marche com - christian
estrosi et d'autres et ceux qui pensent
déjà à la prêt à faire une droite dure
différente avec eric zemmour ou non mais
qui voit qu'ils regardent déjà ailleurs
donc c'est un parti en train de se
fissurer de se scinder en deux sans le
dire avec ce congrès qui arrive en
décembre c'est incompréhensible en terme
de timing pour finalement choisir un
candidat peut-être un peu trop tard
alors que xavier bertrand lui le voulait
ce congrès est ce qu'il est la garantie
selon vous on comprend votre propos que
pas forcément mais est ce qu'il est la
garantie de l'unité de du rassemblement
des candidats à l'issue du vote au moins
dépendre à lui évidemment parce qu'il
peut refuser ce sommet comme il le
voulait c'est peut-être une victoire
pour lui c'est aussi une façon de calmer
l'hypothèse bertrand et de rassurer les
candidats qui voulait une primaire donc
c'est un peu un entre deux difficile ce
qui va se passer là dans les semaines
qui viennent c'est que chacun va faire
campagne
à sa façon les uns contre les autres
pour essayer d'aller chercher les
militants des républicains mais pas
allés chercher les français c'est ça qui
risque d'être difficile à la fin c'est
comment être un candidat rassembleur
plus large que celui qui aura fait de la
politique interne ça rappelle un peu le
parti socialiste avant sa chute on est
vraiment là dedans dans les derniers
jours je pense les derniers mois des
républicains à suivre donc merci alexis
poulain d'avoir été avec nous
aidons les dans l'actualité également
bientôt la fin des tests gratuits de
dépistage de covin le premier ministre
l'a confirmé ce week-end à partir du 15
octobre les tests pcr et antigénique
dits de confort deviendront payantes se
porte mal son nom d'ailleurs confort
pour ces tests si je peux me permettre
ce trait d'humour ils continueront
d'être remboursés pour raisons médicales
son besoin de prescription pour les
personnes vaccinées une décision qui a
pour objectif d'alléger des frais de
dépistage mais surtout densité toujours
plus est la vaccination
et la vaccination qui fait défaut en
guyane seuls 30 % de la population a
reçu une injection antique au bide la
guyane qui vient d'enregistrer 21 décès
en une semaine rapporté à la population
de 300 mille habitants c'est un triste
record du jamais vu même durant la
première vague antoine car ancien
président du conseil régional de la
guyane ancien sénateur appelle le
gouvernement à déployer davantage de
moyens pour endiguer l'épidémie
comment pouvez vous fermez 750 km de
frontière même en mettant un militaire
un gendarme tous les 50 mètres vous
savez que les gens circulant de tout
temps et les frontières ne peuvent pas
être fait elles sont fermées de façon
théorique mais sur le plan pratique il
ya une circulation des biens des
personnes en permanence 24 heures sur 24
alors ce n'est pas là qu'il faut agir il
faut agir autrement mettre les moyens là
où il faut et me tiens à la frontière
franco-brésilienne à la frontière
franco-italienne des moyens le le choc
par exemple ces 8 8 8 lits en
réanimation pour un hôpital aussi
important récent et qui n'a pas les
moyens de sa politique il faut agir
autrement il faut agir mieux il faut
être plus efficace et ce sont des moyens
qui nous manque la guyane a une histoire
structurel avec ces questions sanitaires
en guyane est tous les moyens qui
doivent être mis aujourd'hui doivent se
concentrer sur les moyens humains et les
moyens matériels restez avec nous dans
quelques instants notre rubrique on
pense les français nous sommes allés à
la rencontre des habitants de la cité
des tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes
régulièrement à la une de l'actualité
pour des affrontements entre jeunes et
policiers les politiques ont-ils la
bonne approche contre est il vraiment la
réalité du terrain alors que les
candidats à la présidentielle déclarés
ou non ont tous tort aux positions et
leurs idées sur le sujet
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs là arrivent à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terrorisme est-ce que vous
êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui
a été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda est taliban ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent y va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre devoir moral que de venir en
aide à ce peuple qui a souffert tant par
le passé
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
à la veille d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction tant est que ce soit
possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnées
[Musique]
cette réforme du franc cfa ne semble pas
faire l'unanimité sur le continent
l'avenue bois zunu bouclé sa propre
monnaie et des points c'est la politique
qui va être au coeur du processus de
création monétaire parce que la monnaie
est un fait social total ce n'est pas
qu'on fait économique cette monnaie
cedeao ne pourrait être un succès que
s'il ya un véritable engagement des
états en termes de solidarité est ce que
la réforme du franc cfa va permettre de
couper ce cordon ombilical avec la
france il y a des gens qui sont dans la
défense d'un système qui a vécu c'est
sur le système de la françafrique
avec le français phare qui me semblait
que le dernier avatar de la colonisation
française en arctique
[Musique]
non
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
programme c'est d'abord de notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français à
l'heure où les candidats à la
présidentielle déclarés ou non
commencent à faire leurs propositions
sur la politique de la ville et des
quartiers nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des habitants de la cité des
tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes
régulièrement à la une de l'actualité
pour des affrontements entre jeunes et
policiers
alors comment peut-on rétablir la
communication entre ces deux acteurs que
l'on nous pose en permanence les
politiques ont-ils la bonne stratégie
comprennent t'il vraiment la réalité du
terrain nous en discuterons avec nos
invités
un concert de rap interrompu par des
affrontements entre bandes rivales ces
deux tristes résumé de la soirée de
samedi à rillieux-la-pape commune de la
banlieue lyonnaise une trentaine
d'individus armés de barres de fer ont
tenté de pénétrer dans la salle de
spectacle pour empêcher le concert de se
tenir un nouvel épisode de violence qui
a poussé la mairie à prendre des
décisions fortes et explications en
images
[Musique]
des affrontements entre bandes rivales
dans la banlieue lyonnaise qui font
réagir aujourd'hui le syndicat de police
alliance il dépend aussi de la
banalisation de ces actes de violence
illustration de ce malaise dans la cité
des tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes en
région parisienne des émeutes qui ont
éclaté pendant cinq jours après
l'arrestation musclée d'un jeune lors
d'un rodéo urbain ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudres une vidéo montrant la mère
de ce jeune repoussé par le jet d'un
gain du gaz lacrymo d'un policier alors
qu'elle se dirigeait vers son fils
plaqué au sol nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ces jeunes de cette cité
des tarterets une jeunesse qui appelle
au dialogue avec les politiques et la
police dont l'acteur omar soumaré place
donc à notre rendez-vous qu'en pensent
les français avec guillemard aussi ce
soir je suis dans le quartier des
tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes avec omar
soumaré acteurs et enfants du quartier
qui a ressenti la nécessité de témoigner
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous souhaitez
parler à ce micro aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr il est plus qu'important
d'aujourd'hui parler de de ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours dans mon
quartier ça c'est obligé un objet de
prendre la parole sur des choses qui ne
changent pas qui ce conflit qui ce truc
non au musée de prendre la parole et si
le fait que je prends la parole
aujourd'hui peut changer quelque chose
par la suite entre les forces de l'ordre
et les habitants de ce quartier
sûrement l'un des plus heureux que vous
leur dites aux forces de l'ordre je leur
dis tout simplement un moment donné des
d'essayer de se familiariser avec avec
les avec les habitants de delhi où il
travaille on a deux patrouilles ici qui
tourne régulièrement dans le quartier et
qui eux sont là que
pour la majorité du temps faire les gros
mois et tout on est beaucoup dans
dans je suis le seul moi qui décide et
l'autre côté on ne me laisse pas faire
parler de ces jeunes qui quittent
parfois arrivent pas à communiquer avec
les forces de l'ordre pour quelles
raisons les jeunes ils ont du mal à
s'exprimer avec la police tout de suite
c'est le rapport de force ils ont pas le
temps de pouvoir parler avec eux eu
des forces de l'ordre profite de ça les
fasse de l'autre camp d'en face d'eux un
mec qui leur répondra alors casse btp et
vous faites vite passer à autre chose
mais quand il tombe sur un abruti à ce
moment là ils sont là ils sont ils sont
il embête il embête il embête si je suis
époux et le gamin il sait plus quoi dire
il va jusqu'à outrages du roi c'est son
seul moyen de défense
tout
savoir de haut comment tu vois tu perds
tout le quartier on a grandi ici depuis
tout à l'heure il ya
deux
ans on fait quoi qu'on ait saison ici
quant à 16 ans ici bas coupe ça dépend
si tu as été cité quelque part acteurs
ben j'ai pas été acteur à 16 ans 1 je
n'ai pas et un cabas 24 ans 25 ans donc
c est à ça peut être même de la chance
maintenant quand ta saison ici soit
été assidus à l'école était quelqu'un
voilà qui qui c'est mais t'as pas le
droit à 16 ans tu as paroisse de ne pas
savoir ce que tu veux faire ma vie parce
que sinon tu évites entraînée par les
parlers mauvaise ambiance par les
mauvais délire
par les mauvaises fréquentations et ça
c'est une réalité qu'on ne peut pas
qu'on peut pas qu'on peut pas qu'on peut
pas négliger vous faisiez quoi vous
adolescents ici à corbeil-essonnes à
l'époque on a eu la chance de pouvoir
les faire du camping
d'idées voilà
des de la spéléo du
du kayak
de la plongée sous-marine on et de voilà
on a eu beaucoup plus d'ogm et c'est
vrai que des fois j'ai pitié je me dis
vous voulez gaz est vraiment pas
de chance je peux te montrer plusieurs
gamins qui eux ne connaissent rien de
alors mu corbeil ils connaissent que
corbeil et rien d'autre et ça c'est une
réalité
et on en veut aussi à un moment donné au
service jeunesse actuelle qui est lui à
délicate ils ont pris la décision de
délaisser cette génération une élection
présidentielle l'an prochain qu'est-ce
qui pourrait dire les candidats qui qui
vous convaincrais
moi franchement politique faut vraiment
prendre n'importe quelle personne peu
importe la personne c'est quelqu'un qui
vient qui avaient été les hommes je veux
faire ça pour coller il faudrait qu'il
dise quoi il faudrait il va m'en tire
donc pourquoi ce positionnement sera
là on est là pour moi le réel problème
le réel problème c'est pas ça enfin
c'est ça ça reste un problème est qu'on
réglera peut-être jamais mais le vrai
problème aujourd'hui c'est les personnes
qui râlent qui cohabitent ici ce qui
cohabitent ici ce sont la police et les
jeunes
le premier grand pas
c'est désert dans un premier temps que
ces deux
ce que c'est d'eux que ces deux camps la
sentent enfin s'entendre compliqué mais
que tout le monde met un peu de tout le
monde comme un peu le jeu et une
violence dans les quartiers véritable
fléau qui s'est installée de manière
durable alors pour calmer le jeu quelles
réponses apporter à ces jeunes les
politiques sont-ils trop déconnecté de
la réalité de terrain c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir michel larive
député la france insoumise de l'ariège
bonsoir michel hary merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés pierre frédéric billets
mer les républicains de dreux bonsoy
matière frédéric biais merci d'être avec
nous il faut calmer le jeu viennent nous
dire à l'instant omar soumaré pointant
du doigt principalement des programmes
des problèmes on l'a entendu de
communication et de compréhension avec
la police vous pierre frédéric billets
l'élu d'une ville avec une banlieue pas
toujours simple vous vous partagez ce
diagnostic
oui la question qui se pose en réalité
toujours la même c'est à dire entre la
prévention l'action qu'on peut mener sur
le terrain et puis la répression qui est
tout tout à fait nécessaire sa vie d'ado
une année longue expérience dans ce
secteur là effectivement on a connu des
années qu'ils étaient difficiles on a
mis en place à l'époque mon prédécesseur
le pas ce qui était une sorte de
combinaison entre de la prévention de
l'action sociale mais aussi de la
répression plus de police municipale de
la vidéoprotection et en 25 ans on à
diminuer la délinquance à dreux de 40%
alors que dans le même temps au niveau
national la délinquance avait augmenté
de 10 points donc on peut faire des
chaussures terrain on peut on peut se
mobiliser mais il faut que tous les
acteurs se mobilisent c'est à dire les
services de la ville et les services de
l'état les associations pour voir des
résultats qui sont probants pour notre
population
on entendait également aux marques
soumaré dit il ya seulement deux
patrouilles a un qui tournait la
majorité du temps et bien c'est pour
faire les gros bras dans ces conditions
à ce qu'on peut vraiment faire revenir
l'ordre républicain avec cette vision
michel larive
tout d'abord je te lancer
cette discussion après ce qui s'est
passé à yola pas
c'est malheureusement
je lis nous allons toujours le même
constat et je connais sont autant des
causes les causes elles sont sociales
j'entends ce que dit monsieur le maire
j'acquiesce à beaucoup de ses propos
maintenant c'est aussi cet abandon des
services de proximité des services
publics de
toute cette paupérisation aussi de ces
quartiers qui font que effectivement il
ya un moment donné un vide républicain
qui s'installe la nature ayant horreur
du vide
d'autres s'ils s'y installent et
peut-être pas les meilleurs d'entre nous
maintenant il ya effectivement des
solutions les solutions c'est de revenir
de reprendre place de redonner des
moyens à la police de proximité pas
forcément
des policiers qui sont là pour le
chiffre mais essayer justement comme le
disait ce jeune homme de d'entrer en
relation avec les populations moi j'ai
une proposition nous avons des
propositions à faire c'est la relation
poli citoyens grâce on pourrait être
organisé des rencontres annuelles
notamment dans chacun des spl à
l'initiative des collectivités je pense
pas le seul mais à boxer ça se fait dans
d'autres villes il faut trouver des
solutions et ses solutions sont sociales
à ce qu'il y à 40 ans que nous parle de
politique de banlieue et depuis 40 ans
rien ne s'est amélioré bien au contraire
alors il faut vraiment vraiment prendre
le mal à la racine est là le mal et les
social c'est le manque d'emploi le
nombre de services de proximité des
commerces et le manque de
de service public tous ces services
publics sont partis ailleurs nous avons
la même discrimination en banlieue qu'on
peut la voir dans le monde global
notamment dans mon département c'est à
dire que les gens se retrouvent la seule
seule phase effectivement à un vide un
vide républicain et donc d'autres
traînent la place et c'est tout à fait
dommage je crois qu'il faut que l'état
reprenne pied pas seulement les
collectivités territoriales à qui on
demande beaucoup et à qui on ne donne
pas forcément les moyens notamment
financiers
je crois que l'état doit revenir avec
les services publics avec une police de
proximité pas seulement de renforcement
de bacs de choses souder ou de zones aux
deux structures comme celle là mais des
polices de proximité vous parlez de
caméras monsieur le maire j'entends ceux
ci mais la relation humaine comme le
précise ce jeune dans ce reportage
auparavant tout aussi important je pense
que c'est si c'est d'ailleurs la
première chose à faire et c'est ce qui
se faisait à un moment donné c'est ce
qui se faisait à un moment donné alors
deux patrouilles par jour je pense que
les policiers sont eux aussi mal à
l'aise que la population un moment donné
il va falloir rétablir le contact et
surtout repenser ses banlieues repenser
château mais comment on rétablit ce
contact 1 dont parle michel larive vous
êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic il faut
ramener les services publics dans dans
les cités et d'ailleurs pourquoi ça a
disparu on va pas reparler la police de
sécurité avec monsieur sarkozy m'enfin
y'a pas que ça c'est un manque de
volonté politique
qu'est ce qu'on sait comment l'expliquer
il ya plusieurs choses dans ce qui vient
dire monsieur le député et on était la
question est globale et complexe si on
veut avoir des résultats il faut
intervenir de manière massive l'anru qui
a été lancée à l'époque par jean louis
borloo en 2003 est un très bon exemple
toutes les collectivités qui se sont
lancés dans la rénovation en profondeur
des quartiers ont des très bons
résultats dont l'a fait sur l'ensemble
urbain de vernouillet la première phase
a consisté à investir 211 millions
d'euros pour raser des quartiers
reconstruire des maisons des petits
collectifs etc en remettant des
commerces au coeur tout un dispositif à
dreux de mairie de quartier qui ont des
conseils citoyens qui ont des
investissements qui vont de la formation
sur l'ambiance du quartier on travaille
en lien avec la police municipale la
police nationale les associations les
centres sociaux qu'on est en train de
remettre en place bref c'est une action
globale parce qu'on peut pas traiter la
chut on est tous d'accord n'était pas
traitée de manière répressive uniquement
ou de manière préventive uniquement
voyez il ya des choses qui sont qu'on
peut traiter de manière plus douce ou de
manière plus subtile et puis des maîtres
des choses qu'on ne peut pas laisser
passer et c'est là où l'état tout son
rôle à jouer notamment l'anru
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie question
pour tous les maires qui ont des
quartiers en rue ou est longue mais
aujourd'hui on se pose vraiment beaucoup
de questions
alors la sécurité en tout cas on l'aura
bien compris en ce début de deux
campagnes déjà bien amorcée pour pour
certains tous les candidats à la
présidentielle présentent leurs petites
recettes emmanuel macron tiens prenez de
vie qui n'est pas encore déclarée promet
par exemple de doubler sur 10 ans la
présence de policiers et de gendarmes
sur le terrain ça doit vous faire
plaisir michel larive c'est ce qu'il
faut clairement parce que c'est pas
forcément ce que demande le jeune on a
rencontré un
non madame oui mais
ça suffit pas monsieur le maire va très
bien dit il lui faut à partir du moment
où il ya des vies qui est d'origine donc
à partir de ce moment là il faut de la
répression mais il faut aussi la
prévention mais qu il faut repenser les
choses nous paraît de sécurité donc
d'insécurité
l'insécurité sociale déjà cette
insécurité sociale qui fait que dans
ceux dans cette danse dans 16 zones
urbaines là il ya une paupérisation qui
fait que de toute manière cette
insécurité sociale va mener à un
décalage
société c'est très clair il se passera
alors lorsque les moyens ne sont pas là
aussi venir justement au moyen de la
famille il ya des dérives artistes qui
sont pas les meilleures pourquoi parce
que l'emploi n'est pas là parce que le
l'habitat vous parlez de rénovation
monsieur le maire vous avez tout à fait
raison il faut repenser la rénovation
urbaine des quartiers il faut favoriser
les transports collectifs le jeune homme
disait moi j'avais au kayak j'allais
ailleurs il faut il faut que les gens
puissent sortir des quartiers il faut
qu'on puisse avoir la des pôles de santé
il faut qu'on puisse avoir la des pôles
de sport culture et puis et puis il
songe oublier bien sûr c'est police de
proximité qui doit être là mais en
contact une police républicaine en
contact avec la population
j'ai dis donc dans le tarn s'est
réveillé c'est vrai que ce débat
malheureusement on l'a souvent pas que
sur ce plateau mais voilà dans la
société en général c'est vrai qu'on
entende et il faut il faut mais pourquoi
on n'y arrive pas pourquoi est ce si
compliqué est ce que c'est un manque de
volonté politique est ce que la réalité
est plus difficile finalement ce sont
des des choses difficilement mais à
mettre enfin pardon difficilement metab
en oeuvre ses loisirs sur le terrain oui
c'est forcément compliqué il s'agit il
faut pas avoir d' idéologie là dessus
il ya un cadre républicain il faut le
faire respecter moi je pense aussi aux
forces de l'ordre qui font un travail
fantastique tous les jours et parfois je
pense à lui parce que je me dis mais
mais quel travail c'est un puissant fou
parfois il ya des choses très graves qui
se passe et la réponse pénale n'est pas
au niveau et moi je pense aux gendarmes
et aux policiers qui ne sont des fois
désespéré par le travail et pour moi je
suis admiratif de l'entrain et très
franchement savait que moi en plus je
viens du ministère de l'intérieur donc
je connais bien cette problématique là
mais savez la police de proximité
on l'a supprimé on voulait leur mettre
en place et c'était en réalité sur
beaucoup de communes en france elle est
réelle puisque les conventions police
nationale police municipale existe et
selon la volonté du maire et du
commissaire de police ou du préfet dans
un département à se mettre en place il
ya le clspd savez de contraintes mais ce
qui a été plein sur la délinquance avec
la convention et nous a dream of et or
mais deschamps en pédestre on met des
gens en contact aller voir les
commerçants etc steira il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas de zone de non droit à dreux
on va partout parce que il ya une assise
d'accompagnement associatif social qui
est assez assez puissante une police qui
est de proximité et quand il ya des
choses plus compliquées on sait aussi
intervenir au bon niveau bref il faut
voir des choses proportionnée et puis
surtout il faut aller vers les gens
alors du côté de jean luc mélenchon on
avance des propositions dans le
programme l'avenir en commun on les a
regardés page 22 par exemple la france
insoumise veux faire je cite la police
républicaine regardez c'est donc ces
propositions de ont été retenus par
notre attention pour ce débat de ce soir
programme l'avenir en commun vous
proposé à michel larive de démonter la
bac est de légaliser l'usagé du cannabis
pour désencombrer désencombrer la police
c'est ça qui va ramener selon vous du du
lien social
alors vous avez pris deux mesures qui
font chez petit mot paris on a bien
d'autres
dénoncer les bacs pourquoi parce que
ton dans ses banlieues s'est pas
démentie
des services qui sont spécialisés dans
l'ems certaines situations qui sont
compliqués quelquefois c'est au vu de ce
qu'il fait pas fait regardez là
dernièrement pour un ticket de métro un
jeune homme d'un père d'anne vous le
voyez ce que je veux dire ça c'est
compliqué alors non si vous savez
l'aboutissement de la violence d'où
qu'elle provienne c'est la mort on le
voit dans l'heureux tous les jours ah
non donc à partir de ce moment là il
faut nous disons qu'il faut une police
républicaine pour
la population pour le peuple et pour le
peuple comme toute chose en service
public donc à partir de ce moment que
dans cette proposition ensuite sur la
légalisation du cannabis la légalisation
du cannabis je ne parle seul à le dire
je peux ya aussi dans la majorité
beaucoup et même 1 dans le groupe heller
d'autres commencent à dire effectivement
c'est une proposition qui pourrait
régler en tout cas le problème d'offre
et de demain et qui pourrait régler le
le cas dans tous les cas de figures de
ce marché parallèle qui se met en place
alors là dessus aussi il y à dire c'est
que la pause la police à ce que c'est
les contraintes qu'on lui a donnée est
dans une politique de chiffres et donc
elle elle fait sa politique de cycle il
faut donc arrêter ça il faut
essayer de donner des moyens pour
essayer de
régler les affaires judiciaires et pas
seulement de faire du chiffre et régler
les affaires judiciaires en amont c'est
à dire peut-être sur des trafics ont un
peu plus important il faut peut-être
assécher le trafic en amour et puis et
puis revenir effectivement vers une
police plus
surtout dans les quartiers une police
qui sera de toutes petites fuites il
faudra être qu'elle soit quelque part
c'était par la population puisque la
populaire la police et républicaine
aussi ce n'est pas un service à part
c'est un service public comme tous les
autres services publics donc au service
des populations donc effectivement nous
proposons qu'elle soit autrement fait et
le qu'aujourd'hui alors à droite
justement proposition de xavier bertrand
candidat présidentiel qui a présenté son
programme sécurité le 15 septembre
dernier regardez
ce que je propose c'est la mise en place
maintenant de peines minimales
obligatoires il n'y aura plus d'impunité
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on change de
comportement avec nos policiers et nos
gendarmes nos mères c'est un voeu
peut-être pieux retour des peines
plancher c'est la bonne idée pierre
frais des lignes et
oui c'est une piste qui est qui a si
récurrentes et qu'on a pu explorer après
il ya les modalités de mise en place
mais je pense que vous avez bertrand a
fondamentalement raison maintenant je
voulais juste venir sur sur un point qui
me semble important la police française
et républicaine par définition
intrasèquement faut pas confondre dans
toute profession il ya des écarts il ya
les gpl qui sanctionne j'ai pas de doute
là dessus sur la bac bon démente et là
bas que je suis plus réservé parce qu'il
nous faut des interventions de type
spécialisés on changera le nom savez
c'est un peu comme l'ena en feront
supprimer la mort de nos nouveaux noms
mais ça reste l'ena en fait mais oui il
faut des fois des missions plus musclée
je pense que les évolutions aussi à
faire sur l'inspection générale de la
police nationale c'est une vraie
question et ça c'est un débat de fond
bon maintenant sur le cannabis auprès
ouveillan débat j'ai ma position de
celui-ci mais je pense que là ça ce soir
c'est ce qu'un peu trop long
michel larive finalement on vous voit
pas beaucoup beaucoup de deux points de
discorde tous les deux il ya un lien
entre la france insoumise et et les
républicains quand on se retrouve
peut-être sur le seul sur le terrain se
montrent ces quartiers difficiles
écoutez nous sommes tous les deux
républicain jonh en félicite j'ai dit
bon je vais pas moi donner des leçons à
monsieur le maire qui lui est sur le
terrain de la commune c'est le premier
espace d obliger tocqueville disait
quelque chose comme ça et bien à partir
de ce moment là j'ai le plus grand
respect pour l'oeuvre de monsieur le
maire et des gens sur le terrain donc je
vais m'acheter loi j'ai mon idée nous
sommes un mouvement politique nous avons
des idées qui sont en contradiction
souvent avec le républicain mais quand
il s'agit de la république et il s'agit
de nos enfants effectivement on peut
trouver des
des choses city qui vont des réchauds
jury qui vont dans le même sens et bien
pour moi c'est très très grave je dire
si ça mais on va vers la vie et pas vers
la manche jeune homme est mort pour un
ticket de métro donc moi je suis ici
monsieur le maire à me dire oui je suis
d'accord en mai +2 de gens au contact de
la population c'est ce que nous voulons
si on papa contredire monsieur le maire
pour le contredira principe s'il le faut
le dire assez bien et puis voilà et donc
à partir de ce moment là nous avons si
nous avons des désaccords sur suturer
manière de faire une petite échelle
merci en tout cas à tous les deux michel
larive pierre frédéric bihet d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce débat ce soir merci à
vous et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain pour à 20h pour un nouveau numéro
prochain point sur l'actualité ce sera
dans une trentaine de minutes
l'actualité qui continue toute la soirée
sur rtl france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coups politiques n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
en soi vient des lignes ans